thanks for coming out I think we're
gonna go ahead and get started so this
is testing for data scientists with me
Trey cause II I appreciate that you've
come to all sit in a dark windowless
room and talk about software testing
that either means you have a very
specific interests or it sounded
interesting to you or something along
those lines but I thanks for coming out
you can find these slides online I
started not supposed to move around too
much you can find these slides online at
the URL there i'm on twitter at at Trey
Kazi so if you have questions that I
don't get to or anything like that feel
free to tweet at me and that's my
personal website right there so just
kind of little detail about Who I am by
day I am a data scientist at Daddo which
is based here in Seattle we build
machine learning software and we're also
a sponsor of Pi data Seattle nights and
weekends I'm kind of a sports analytics
fan did I my mic just drop out or is
that just me cool all right
so nights and weekends like I'm a sports
analytics guy I do a lot of sports data
do a little bit of that for pay a lot
for fun so if you're into the kind of
intersection of sports and data science
I've got a blog that's never updated and
you can visit it right there
hopefully that's gonna change very soon
football seasons about to start all
right so what am I gonna talk about
today it's really kind of two talks and
so probably some of you'll be
disappointed at one of these talks and
some of you will be glad that you came
for for the other section the first half
is gonna be kind of like well what is
software testing why do we want to do it
what data scientists particularly want
to do software testing kind of one of
the kinds of tests that we want to run
on our software and then a quick review
of unit testing which if you're familiar
with it won't be anything new but if
you've never done any kind of software
testing before it might give you a quick
quick start on how to start testing the
second half is gonna be a little bit of
a bait and switch and I'm gonna say
actually all this unit testing stuff
maybe isn't great for a lot of typical
data science problems and I'm gonna talk
about why that's the case and I'm gonna
show you some promising packages that
are available in the Python ikan system
right now that start to address some of
these things so just let me know if you
have questions feel free to interrupt
I'm a fast talker so you can also tell
me to slow down and I'll probably ignore
you all right so if you're like me many
data scientist kind of started off in
academia so I was in grad school working
on a PhD I thought my life was going to
be you know in the library
working kind of monastic Leon some like
really important question and I was
going to be publishing a paper and it's
gonna be amazing and I was gonna get
patches for my jacket and things like
that and I thought my life was gonna
look like this this is actually Souza
Lowe library which is a here in Seattle
at the u-dub it's the graduate school
library and actually really did spend a
lot of time in that room so for a while
this is what the life of a data
scientist looked like for me in reality
what it looks like for a lot of us is
actually something more like this and
you're not kind of toiling away living
the monastic lifestyle you're actually
working with a bunch of other people and
a lot of those people are not data
scientists they're engineers or they're
in various various other capacities
you're sitting right across from them
they have to use the code that you wrote
and the analyses that you're working on
and you're not gonna be there
necessarily when they do it and that
seems a little crazy at first cuz I
think probably in the past you were like
working on a paper and you got to an
analysis and you wrote up that paper for
publication you submit it to a journal
you had your you know hopes and dreams
dashed when they rejected it and then
you submitted it it's a three or four
more journals and finally after three or
four rounds of revise and resubmit you
publish it somewhere and then you were
done with it and you're like I don't
ever want to see that paper or that data
again please get it away from me I was
done with it a month ago so it's not
like that anymore now the kind of code
that you're writing it's gonna be reused
a lot and it's gonna be like talking to
other pieces of code and it's gonna be
talking touching other pieces of data
that didn't even exist when you
originally wrote your code right so new
data is gonna be coming in via like
customers by your website whatever and
so you have to think about how your code
is gonna interact with that data so
instead of a research paper you know
that you publish or try to publish and
fail or you know some some kind of like
bounded research project your work now
looks something like this where you're
getting data coming in from multiple
sources you're kind of building models
on top of that data you're iterating
through that and then at some point
you're kind of loading the results of
your modeling back into some other
database somewhere and it's um
columnstore or something along those
lines to be consumed by whatever so
instead of a research paper you're now
like predicting click-through rates so
or you're making recommendations or
whatever or you're in scientific
computing you're kind of working at the
intersection of both of these things so
now that your work looks like this and
your code is going to be touching a lot
of different things that it didn't used
to touch when you're working by yourself
you need to think about how to be a good
citizen kind of of that coding ecosystem
so all the data you're gonna be dealing
with is no longer academic data
no we were pretty clean for you it's no
longer like you know it's not m-miss
it's not like you know pre-process for
you and a million eyes have looked at it
and you've figured out like we're all
the kind of difficult and tricky parts
of the data are the data is now real
it's now messy and you've written
equally messy code to go with it because
you probably weren't trained as a
computer scientist maybe you were
awesome but maybe you weren't and you
taught yourself to code it's like kind
of a means to an end
so you've written messy code to deal
with messy data and what you're doing in
each of those steps is you're making
assumptions both about how your code is
going to work about what the data is
going to look like I've switched a data
singular here by the way so if you're a
data plural person we can talk
afterwards what the data is going to
look like and kind of you know how all
this assumptions that you're making are
in a play out and a lot of times you end
up you don't realize you're making
assumption so maybe at the modeling step
you're building a statistical model and
you're like okay well I know some
assumptions to this model is that the
errors are normally distributed with a
mean of 0 and a standard deviation 1 or
so on and so forth or like I assume that
the data is distributed iid you have all
these assumptions that you think
carefully about but when you're actually
writing the code that like you know that
mythical 80% of the your time you know
scraping CSVs like you're not thinking
about like assumptions you're making
about the data as well and you're not
making assumptions about what's gonna
happen when that data in that model come
together so I want to encourage you to
think about testing as a way to make
those assumptions explicit so this is
all kind of inspired a little while back
I wrote a blog post called software
development skills the data scientist
might not know they need and so this
kind of came out of some thinking about
was having so I work with primarily
machine learning engineers now and
they're all like really good software
engineers as well as machine learning
experts so it's terrifying and you know
will give you a posture syndrome but
they're really good software engineers
and they're like ways of like working on
a collaborative software like
collaborative code base together with
people right and a lot of people coming
out of academia has particular data
scientists don't know that they're gonna
need to do these things so these things
include like writing modular reusable
code or like the single responsibility
principle or don't repeat yourself these
kinds of acronyms that you hear
writing good documentation and comments
not like read data build model you know
those kinds of documents the
documentation you probably wrote at some
point when you're working on your
academic research if you're at any
comments at all things like distributed
version control and then testing and
logging and I think
I think it's kind of like actually has
its fingers in all of these other points
as well but I'm gonna focus on testing
for the most part so I'm not gonna give
a comprehensive overview of what testing
is or like you know give you tons of
examples of how to do it because Ned
Batchelder did a much better job than I
can do of that so at PyCon 2014 if you
want like a real deep dive into how to
write unit tests and the kind of
philosophy of writing unit tests as well
as how to use the unit test package in
python i would recommend watching this
plus medicine amazing speaker and it's
just a good talk to watch so I'm not
gonna give you that I will give you a
very shallow introduction which won't be
useful to you alright so as data
scientists think I want to think about
like when do I start writing tests
because you maybe have an raise your
hand if you've never written a test for
the code that you've written it's okay
everybody look forward and raise your
hand if you've okay so substantial
number of you have never written a test
before and a substantial number of you
are lying but there are definitely
people in the audience that have never
kind of written test for their code and
so they might think like well when do I
test when do I need a write test for my
code right there are lots of different
steps in in data science and we've all
heard of ETL the kind of extract
transform load paradigm every single
step there you should be like writing
tests for your code extracting
transforming loading because you're
making assumptions about what the data
that you're extracting looks like what
you're transforming it into and what how
it's gonna be loaded back into somewhere
else but there's also the modeling stuff
and this is kind of like the Wild West
as far as testing goes because it's not
clear what it means actually to write
tests for probabilistic algorithms a lot
of the time so I'm gonna talk a little
bit more in detail about that but that's
kind of a I would say the ETL part of
this is kind of the first half of the
talk and then the second half the talk
is the modeling part anyone have any
questions so far I'm gonna get my phone
out because I need to know how much how
long I'm taking here and I have like no
clue how long we're taking all right
perfect
so why do we write tests for our
software so people will say it's still
like you know ensure correctness and
then some people say no you're not
ensuring correctness you're having more
confidence in correctness and we can
debate this whatever basically what
testing does it helps you a find bugs
that's the kind of obvious reason you
would write tests it helps you check
your assumptions that you
so I've kind of made multiple reference
to this that's a hobby horse of mine it
helps you write simpler code because as
I'm going to show you like unit tests
and software tests should only be kind
of testing one unit of code hence the
name like one small piece of code that
does one thing and if you find you're
having a hard time writing a test for
your code then it might actually be the
problem that you might need to simplify
your code to make that easier but it
also makes you a good citizen of working
with a code base and people have more
confidence that the code that you are
checking into their code base isn't
gonna explode when someone else is on
page or duty like you know at midnight
on Saturday or something like that and
like I've had a lot of people tell me
that like oh I don't like working with
data scientists because they write
terrible code and they're not good good
citizens of the code base and as a
result like everything breaks and I'm on
call for it so testing helps other
people have confidence that you've
thought about how your code might break
and you've like develop solutions for it
and I think ultimately the nice thing
about is it helps you be surprised less
so that sounds boring like we're all in
a windowless room talking about testing
but it helps you like not be surprised
when you don't want to be surprised so
because being surprised is never a good
thing once your data is like out there
or what's your models out there hitting
production data and so on and so forth
so make your life more boring boring is
good you know boring technology is good
so I've kind of been using the word
testing and unit testing interchangeably
for the most part but there are multiple
kinds of tests so I think when most
people say tests they mean unit tests
and we're gonna spend a little bit of
time on those but I think also for data
sizes some important things are
regression tests which is like the most
overloaded term ever right like oh I
found a regression of my data you say
that so data scientists like what does
that mean you found a regression in your
data like so you know regression tests
are when you find a bug and you write a
test for it and you make sure that that
bug never shows up again so let's say
you find a bug in like your ETL code or
kind of feature hands formation code or
something like that and for some reason
it's introducing like not a number
somewhere some like that well you can
reproduce their steps and a test and
then make sure that when you change the
code later
you don't reintroduce that bug at any
point because probably you introduce
that bug because you made an assumption
and you're gonna make that assumption
again because thinking is automatic a
lot of the times but especially when
writing code so there you go and then
integration tests I think are super
important for data scientists because
they're basically like the way multiple
pieces of code talk to each other so
I'm gonna talk a little bit about what
that means but that's kind of like the
crux of what I think a lot of what we do
every day is like we're having lots of
different data sources talk to each
other we want to make sure that code
plays nicely with each other so we want
to like extract some code build some
features out of it fit into a machine
learning model make predictions based on
that model and then feed those
predictions back into some other
database all right so this is the boring
part for you if you've already written
tests but if you've never written tests
this is going to be your like
lightning-fast introduction to what a
unit test is so as I kind of said before
unit test to the idea of testing kind of
one unit of code so you can think of a
unit it's like a function right so you
just want to test one function and that
function should only do one thing and
you want to make sure that does it
correctly so if you're creating a
function like I'm gonna show you in a
second to compute the mean of an array
you want to make sure that that
correctly computes the mean of our array
so this is kind of contrived and it's
not a very useful example pool gets a
why that is the idea is that it
shouldn't depend on any other code that
you yourself have written because then
it's an integration test and then you
also have the assumptions based into the
other code you've written baked into
this code as a dependency and third it
shouldn't these tests shouldn't require
access the databases or API so I think
so mission run locally and they should
run quickly and I know that might sound
counterintuitive because I just said
like which is all about ETL and this is
all about different kinds of data
talking to each other we'll talk about
what that looks like
so the standard kind of Python unit
testing landscape looks like this I am a
fierce PI test advocate I'm I prefer
much more than units that's for unit
tests too I'm gonna show you why in a
second there's also nose which runs test
Suites fixtures and mock which enable
you to fool your tests or kind of
simulate connecting to databases or AP
is within your test so you don't
actually have to go out and hit the API
when you're writing the test you can set
up a mock that like makes the code think
for this actually hitting the API and
returning some kind of response so that
way you can always run it even if that
particular API is down when you're
developing so I want to talk about PI
tests in the most detail so here's a
kind of simple example great a punch and
hold mean that accepts values and we're
gonna return the sum of those values
divided by the length of those values
like what could possibly go wrong with
this code yeah the list is empty
absolutely what else can go wrong with
this good yeah
types of values absolutely what else
land could be zero absolutely so that be
divided by zero overflow what else yes
why do I have issues in Python - that's
right so these are all things like
you're like this is literally the
formula for the mean right but these are
all things that could go wrong and we
haven't said what values looks like
where values is going to be coming from
like maybe values is like an array
that's coming in off the network and I'm
trying to find like the average load for
a particular device or something like
that or maybe you mean is data that I
always have historically like these are
things we would want to think about but
those are all things that could go wrong
in this case so I'm gonna show you a
very contrived simple looking tests that
to get you thinking about like how you
would write tests for those different
scenarios so I'm gonna use PI doubt test
because it's it's really nice and this
is a simple a simple example right here
so in a in a separate in a separate
module usually you want to separate your
test code from your application code
usually I create a function here called
test underscore main and there are what
are called test discovery rules in
Python so if you name a file or method
with a certain test underscore beginning
all the test Suites will automatically
detect that those are tests and should
be run so here I'm making an assertion
so this is the simplest kind of of Units
si masseur ting that the mean of this
list of values would be equal to 2
that's clearly incorrect the mean of
these values would be 3 but that you
actually like it's nice to see a test
fail so if you've never written a test
before I encourage the first test you
write to be a failing test so you see
what that looks like so why do I want to
use PI dot test and why do I want to do
such a silly example so I'll answer the
first one because it's easier to answer
than the second one the pilot test has
no boilerplate code for the most part
it's like you saw it's just writing
functions and making some assertions and
they're like you can assert that certain
errors will raise certain error messages
exceptions and so on if you were to use
unit tests which is the kind of a ships
with Python the standard library testing
library it's based on J unit which is
the Java unit testing library and so
everything has to be encapsulated in a
class that inherits from unit tests our
test case and then you have all this
self nonsense and so on and so forth so
I really recommend
test because it gets you testing quickly
and the cool thing about it too is if I
were to run this code here the assertion
error would give me a meaningful error
message it would say you're asserting
that two equals three and that's clearly
a problem here's the line of your code
that that happened at here's what you
expect it to happen and here's what
happened so it's getting back to this
theme of like making your assumptions
explicit and saying like I assume I am
like assuming that this value is going
to be three are gonna be two in this
case and let's see if that actually
happens okay so kind of general
philosophy of like when and why you
should test so if you've never like
written a test before the next time you
change a piece of code add a test to it
make sure you didn't introduce a new bug
that's a good first place to start you
don't have to go back I don't recommend
going back to all of your old projects
and writing a bunch of tests for them
because probably you have more important
things to do with your time but you know
it could be good practice I don't know I
have like you know like mixed feelings
on some of these aphorisms
but anyway so test the outcome not the
implementation so this is a something
important to think about that a lot of
people don't think about it first you
want to test the answer you don't want
to test how you got to the answer and
the reason you want to do that is then
you can like go and change all the
computation code and maybe make it
faster and refactor it as long as you're
still getting the right answer the test
doesn't care the test is just checking
for the outcome now I just said like
never always and these are obviously
like not good things to say so they're
gonna be cases when you want to actually
do these things but that's fine so the
nice thing is you go and change a bunch
of code run your tests of all the tests
continue to pass you're in good shape if
you find a bug at a test and tests also
help identify complexity so something to
think about
don't test code that's already tested
scikit-learn numpy Sipe i have awesome
test suites you don't need to test to
make sure that they're doing their job
correctly right you need to test the
code that you wrote is doing its job
correctly and don't test don't have
overlapping tests because then if one
test fails the other one doesn't you're
kind of in like a weird state of
undetermined outcome there so don't test
go the tardiness has two test outcomes
not implementations and you know every
time you kind of change the code base
add a test for it so there's this idea
that I vehement ly disagree with called
test-driven development VM Utley
disagree with it but I don't think it's
appropriate for data science for the
most part called test-driven development
and this is like a kind of movement and
there's this whole idea that
what you do is instead of writing your
code first you write tests that are
gonna be run for when your code is done
and you write those tests so that
they'll pass once the code is already
written and so once the code is all
written and your answers are correct so
you keep failing tests to keep failing
tests and you keep changing the code
until this test pass so like in this
case I would start with this test except
I would make this a three and I would
keep writing you know keep adjusting
actual mean function until I got to the
answer I was expecting I think this is a
bad idea for most data science problems
so I think that testing for data science
and this is kind of shifting so the
second part of the talk it's a little
different because a lot of times
deterministic answers don't exist for
your problem necessarily you're getting
probabilistic answers right and
something else dangerous that happens
when you keep writing tests we keep
writing code to to pass your existing
tests is you get some crazy situations
where all of your tests pass because
you've made some strong assumptions
about what the right answers are and
you've gotten like so wrapped up in
making those test paths that your code
isn't actually doing what it wants to do
what you want it to do is just doing
what the tests think it should do so you
know if you think about this from a
machine learning standpoint we actually
have a word for this and it's called
overfitting and this is when your tests
or your basically your code you're
writing to previously written tests and
you're memorizing your past mistakes so
you're memorizing those mistakes
you're changing your code to make sure
those mistakes don't pop up again but
what do we really care about a lot of
times in machine learning models what's
gonna happen in the future right so we
don't want to overfit to our past
examples and get kind of blinders on and
say like well all these tests are
passing now so I think I'm in good shape
we should strive to avoid overfitting
both in our models but also in our
testing so I'm going to talk a little
bit about how I think we can do that and
how we can get around that
so probably we've all done this before
I've done kind of been lazy not in a
good functional way but in the kind of
like you know 7 Deadly Sins kind of way
and we haven't been great about how we
handle our data that we're building
models on so maybe we extracted the data
we wanted once because the data is
painful to extract and it's sitting at
some really slow database or something
like that and we built a lot of models
on top of that data and we've become
very confident about our model and then
oh crap our new data set that we finally
extract it doesn't do very well on or we
think that the data we've seen in the
past
it's gonna be represent of the future
and we weren't very good about cross
validation or training and testing set
and so on and so forth or maybe I know
that we all do this you pick some
examples and the data some specific
samples and you keep you know checking
how your prediction is doing on them as
you're iterating through building your
models that's exactly the kind of
overfitting via testing that I'm doing
in fact if you've never written a test
but you do that you're like why no the
answer should be this for this
particular line this particular sample
and you keep you know building your
model until you get that answer your
testing right there you're just running
them by hand and you're running them on
one particular example so we want to not
do this we want to get it away from this
and I think that what I like as a data
scientist when I when I hear things
about like you know randomness and
probability I get pretty excited so I
want to talk about how we can introduce
randomness and probability into our
testing as well and I think it's really
exciting so I think there are better
ways to move forward better ways to test
things the first thing we can do is we
can take a different approach to testing
rather than thinking up these specific
edge cases that were we're scared about
we can think about properties that we
would like the data to have and
properties that we would like our kind
of results or our models have and test
those and said so those are like those
are the actual assumptions we're making
rather than specific values we can make
assumptions about like what the data
will look like what's shape web what
kind of type it will have and so I was
just in the Python 3.5 session before
this and one of the questions was will
it ever come to pass that the type
hinting that's in three point five will
allow data frames this is hype because
some people might expect you know their
function to take a data frame as an
input and a data frame is an output and
you want to make some assertions about
the kinds of you know D types that that
data frame is made up of and so on and
so forth the answer was no for now but I
think there's someone in the room who
maybe is kind of working on some stuff
like this and then finally I'm going to
talk about testing probabilistic lis so
I think there are three promising
projects and the Python ecosphere right
now they kind of get at the things the
kinds of approaches to testing that I'm
talking about and that's not testing
specific values that's trying to be more
robust about how we build tests the
first is unguarded spurrier who is one
of the developers of pandas and the idea
behind OnGuard is for doing defensive
data analysis what do you mean might
defensive data now so I'm going to
switch back the data are plural here cuz
Tom did that but I firmly and
Rezound Lee disapprove of that so the
idea is that
the Rays on depth is a front guards that
data are messy so let's do some things
about that so I think this is a really
promising package as a very early
development but great for ETL on
changing data so if you have constant
data coming in and you wanna make some
assumptions about that data this
provides a really lightweight way of
doing that and it's built on pandas so
I'm gonna show you what it looks like in
just a second but basically any function
that you have that accepts and returns a
data frame you can just add some
decorators to and automatically kind of
test for the assumptions that you have
about the shape and type of that data or
you can do it interactively using the
pipe method and if you haven't looked at
the pipe method that's been added a
panelist recently is pretty cool so it
just kind of looks like this pretty easy
so we have some function compute that
accepts a data frame as an argument and
returns a result which is also gonna be
a data frame and so we just have three
decorators here that make our
assumptions explicit about what we
expect about this data one we said this
negative one means we don't care how
many rows that it has what we expect it
to have ten columns so it's gonna make
that check for us should the data frame
be monotonic so for instance I work with
a lot of sports data so like we would
expect that the time on the clock is
always going to be decreasing or if you
think about it is one minus the time in
the clock it will always be increasing
right so you can make check for that or
if you have time series data and you
want to make sure that the timestamp is
always increasing something along those
lines you can kind of make those
assumptions and just quickly with the
decorator right there
and it's going to test that for you when
when it runs or there shouldn't be any
missing guys so say that you have an
algorithm that doesn't like missing
values and you need to make sure your
data doesn't have any missing values and
the code that you wrote to get your data
shouldn't produce any missing values
this is like one-liner right here you
can make that check explicit so I think
this is really cool and really promising
and it kind of just encapsulate Sal OTT
of the like ad hoc checks a lot of us do
in our data as we're modeling all the
time but it kind of takes the cognitive
like switching costs out of you just
like I said this and it's gonna do it
for me rather than me having to remember
to do it at all the steps of my analysis
instead of faithful awesome all right so
then the next package that I'm super
excited about that's that's awesome is
called hypothesis and this is based on
Haskell's quick check
there's also Scala check which is the
Scala version of this I think there are
other versions like J check I can't
remember if that's the job the job one
or not
this is a pretty amazing idea and I
think this will appeal to the data
scientist you
so rather than testing for values this
is testing about properties we wouldn't
like make our assumptions about what our
data looks like and the values that are
function return and explicit and we're
gonna randomly generate data and do a
bunch of tests so we don't have to think
of all the edge cases we don't have to
think about the data we want to feed it
we can randomly generate that data
according to some specifications either
like very loose specifications like what
type it is so it's gonna test things
like addresses gonna test things like
strings what happens if the string has
Unicode in it it's not supposed to and
so on and so forth we do all this
automatically for you and it's pretty
awesome and the cool thing about it is
that the author is slightly diabolical
about it as well so like he's a really
fun read on Twitter his like thing is
finding weird corner cases and like
Python itself as well as like in your
data and trying to like find those as
quickly as possible so what happens if
you have two nested lists instead of
three nested lists or like what happens
to get a tuple nested within a list or
what happens if you assigned like just
kind of all the edge cases that you
don't want to think about they're doing
for you and you can also give it
specific values as well so like if you
know there's a value you're gonna see a
lot you can specifically test for that
too so we're kind of similar syntax to
on guard
we're just importing from hypothesis
given which is the basically the
assumptions we're gonna make and then
the kind of assumptions are grouped into
what are called strategies and these are
like data types a lot of the time so
this tests mean function here I'm just
saying hey give it lists of integers so
I want to test this function on lists of
integers in fact when you run it the
first thing it finds is like oh this
doesn't work if the list is empty so
whoever said empty list is the first I
think this yeah first there that's the
very first error that it found then it
kind of runs through a number of other
cases as well so pretty cool and it
comes with a really deep knowledge of
like kind of Python internals silly all
the Python gotchas that you know we've
all forgotten about and then spent a lot
of time debugging code and realizing
this is actually some gotcha in the
language and and so on and so forth
they're all kind of baked in it's very
flexible and it has plugin support so
it's pretty pretty cool for all
different kinds of data
ideal for code that's gonna be like
accepting input from the wild so say
like you're using like free text entry
that customers have in a form and the
like website or something like that and
you want to do some kind of like Lda or
some kind of text modeling on that it
like it's really good with free text and
kind of like really dirty data the other
nice things is it actually just works
with PI tests and knows and all these
other frameworks you just need to add
those decorators and it works a faker
does anybody here ever heard of faker
this is pretty cool yeah so faker will
just generate fake looking realistic
data for you so you can say like give me
a thousand addresses and it'll give you
a thousand fake addresses and you can
specify it with locales and so on and so
forth so you're like give me a hundred
fake addresses in the UK and it would
like you know conform to those kinds of
data types has a date/time plug-in so
like if you hate yourself when you work
with date times all the time
like it will also our site vice-versa
you work with date times all time and
you hate yourself it will it'll generate
all sorts of kind of like diabolical
date/time edge cases to figure out if
your data or your programs actually
handling date times correctly there's
experice of probably most importantly
for data scientists there's experimental
numpy support right now it's on github
but numpy support is not a like
first-class feature right now
so I'm sure PRS are accepted and then
the last thing I'd like to talk about
last package is feature Forge and this
is pretty cool it's a testing package
with machine learning and specifically
scikit-learn in mind so along the same
ideas as they're all decorator based I
actually just realized this just now
along the same kind of path is on guard
and hypothesis it's basically like let's
make our assumptions explicit but not
feed specific values so for instance you
can imagine we have some some code here
that creates let's say we have emails
that are stored in a dictionary and the
body of the email stored with the key
body and so let's say we want to turn
that into a feature in some machine
learning model where like the number of
characters and the email or is it's a
feature or something like that with
feature for which we can specify an
input schema so we expect body to be
Unicode some output schema we expect it
to be an integer and non-negative and
then it's going to generate some some
fake data for us and make sure those
assumptions hold so this goes back to
the laziness like oh you've got data you
pulled out of a database this feature of
creation code you have works great on
that code but you know what that
database is going to be even dirtier
next week like I guess you know
databases tend towards chaos and so like
the data is gonna be Messier next week
and it's gonna hopefully test for some
of those edge cases for you so
specifically built with
feature creation of machine learning in
mind you can actually create pipelines
in the same kind of way that you can in
scikit-learn where you can build model
training pipelines you can build feature
creation and testing pipelines so it
kind of becomes an integration test set
at that point it also this is kind of
weird it seems like I actually haven't
explored this very much but kind of
added on to is an experiments
functionality which is basically you
want to run a bunch of different models
with a bunch of different features and
you want to store the results of those
models and some [ __ ] or some other DB
and it's gonna do that for you
automatically and distribute this but
this seems kind of like a somewhat
overlap with you know grid parameter
search and random CV granted by CV and
cyclone already but yeah so pretty
pretty cool I think the idea for all
three of these is not contrived not hard
coding values and making sure that like
the randomness they and generating the
data that you're running your test with
gets at the corner cases that you
weren't thinking about so I think it's
not actually the case that it's easy to
write tests from for modeling so I'm
gonna talk about that now last
probabilistic testing so model testing
is like I don't actually know I don't
have this is this is a terrible punch
line I don't have a good answer for this
if you came here for a good answer this
I'm sorry but I don't have a good answer
for this because like a lot of times
it's gonna happen like you build a
classifier it's gonna output
probabilities or something like that
right and it's in production and you're
putting those out say every day for a
bunch of customers or something like
that like how do you know if it's
working or not right like it's actually
not totally clear what it means for that
model to be working in fact you can
think about in some ways if it's like
trying to get people to do something on
the website it's gonna get worse over
time because people are gonna start
doing that thing and your features are
not gonna be predictive anymore or so on
and so forth so what does it mean for
these tests to pass I think it means
what does the data that it outputs look
like so I'm guard provides a couple
things here like maybe we assume that
it's mean monotonic in its output or
maybe we assume that our predictions are
going to be within some number of
standard deviations or if it's a
classifier labels that they're all gonna
be within some set of values or
something like that so I actually don't
really know what the answer is and I'd
love to hear thoughts on this and QA or
afterwards about what you think we
should do the caveats all thrown is
don't test algorithms that you haven't
personally implemented there's this is
redundant you don't need to do it
scikit-learn stop by number I have
really excellent test Suites already so
you don't need to make sure that
scikit-learn is doing a logistic
regression correctly if it's not it's
probably with your data it's not with
the secular and I mean you may have
found a bug but that it's more likely
that you have some some issue in your in
your data transformation similarly if
you have implemented an algorithm by
hand with all pandas scifi number I also
have testing methods so numerical
computing is tricky and sucks in a lot
of ways right because it's like you know
you can't assert the two things are
equal necessarily because of you know
underflow and overflow and so on and so
forth
so numpy comes with testing methods to
assert that two arrays are close or that
they're equal to some tolerance and so
on and so forth and Candice has that you
can assert a series is increasing
monotonically or that two data frames
are equal and so on and so forth so use
the testing tools that have already been
built as it makes sense for you kind of
in your model building workflow so I
want to open up for Q&A but let me tell
you what I didn't cover so the first
thing I didn't cover is testing MCMC
code which is like great so if you were
interested in that topic I would
recommend following Tim hopper who is
trying to figure this out for himself
right now so he's at TD hopper on
Twitter I didn't follow things like
continuous integration so this is kind
of the idea that like every time you
check code into a repo all the tests are
run and that that code that that PR is
not accepted into all this tests have
passed and so my friend mark Roddy who's
not here he's a former data engineer at
Etsy now he's a true Cana
he wrote this amazing core answer about
how you test stochastic algorithms from
a data engineering standpoint he jokes
that he's the JD salinger of korah
because he just wrote that one answer
like three years ago and never used
chorus after that but that periodically
like it'll get 50 retweets you know just
because someone else found it so it's
actually a really interesting answer if
you're thinking about this more from the
software engineering standpoint like how
do I throw tests on top of stochastic
algorithms I recommend visiting bitly
slash testing underscore algorithms
alright questions yes
yep hugely that's a great question rob
story do you have anything about that I
actually don't know but if you wanna
hang around afterwards I think maybe
some people might have some ideas about
that Rob do you actually have some ideas
about that cool all right yes totally
yeah I think that the answer is probably
both the key to a lot of testing is that
you want to be fasten automatic because
of test take a long time to run you're
not gonna do it right so if you have to
hit a database every time and say it's
two o'clock in the afternoon that's like
the busiest time in the office and you
know you don't have like very high
priority or something like that you're
gonna not test on new data because
you're just gonna use the data that you
pulled this morning when it's fast and
and whatever I think your combination
for sure so I think when you're kind of
writing a lot of the ETL functions for
the first time it makes sense to use
some randomly generated data and then
pull in real data once this test you're
passing and figure out where to go from
there
but obviously the real data is what you
are gonna be using so I wouldn't
recommend ever using all randomly
generated data and then see you in
deployment you know so yeah yeah yeah it
is
that's a great question that is because
of the contrived test that I kind of
have here yeah yeah that's a really good
question is something you can avoid if
you're Carol bad but if you're testing
the very core functionality about like
there there aren't many things I would
test about this function right like so I
like let's say you know kind of a
contrived example is testing that X plus
y equals y plus X like there's no other
way to test that other than to write
that out again but I would certainly
hope that your tests are not
reimplemented your code because I'm
probably what happens is that your code
is complicated and yeah so right yeah
oh no okay sorry I see what you're
saying yeah so excellent question so we
could yeah in this particular example I
don't know how you would get around that
I haven't used it as much as I would
like I think it's exciting but having
you some punches I would like
that's a good question I'll I'm happy to
follow up with you about it yeah
nice yeah that's great don't feel
terrible about that oh sorry yeah oh
yeah won't feel good about that that
yeah yeah no I don't think I don't think
those two things are in contrast
necessarily I think that so if you're
using simulated data what you want to
test them is you want to make sure that
the simulated data make you know all the
assumptions you've made about what that
data is gonna look like are met the
model itself then this gets into the
trigger you're like how do you know if a
model that you've built on simulated
data is correct unless you have previous
real data that you use the same kind of
model on that's a kind of infinite
recursion problem right like how is my
model correct using simulated data but I
don't think those two things are in
contrast and so when I say testing the
model like I mean let's say you are you
are you implementing the model from my
primitives or using an existing package
like what does that look like for you
usually right yep oh yeah so you want to
recover the parameters that are yeah
absolutely
yeah yeah yeah I think that yeah and
then you want to make some hard
assertions that that data should look
like this I think that's totally fair
yeah I'm not proposing that you should
get rid of all values baked in I'm just
saying I think it's more flexible
workflow for a lot of traditional
modeling questions but that seems like a
reasonable case for you know you want a
hard assertion that this data is equal
to this data essentially that makes
sense of it
any other questions
yeah so that is a really good question
because the data source is broken in a
way that's not obvious then you might
not know it's broken it's just that your
model performance is now gonna look
different than it did in the past and
you're not gonna know why right so I
think this gets back kind of to the
similar question if you have say let's
see you have some assertions you can
make like that the data should will be
noisy right but it should always be
within a couple of standard deviations
of some given value or you know it
should always be within some range you
can make those assertions but if the
data source is broken somehow and still
meets those criteria that's gonna be
very tricky to diagnose in that case
what I would say is you need to make
sure the tests that are implemented on
the where the data is coming from are
implemented correctly right so like that
data is coming from somewhere else and
so if it's being transformed in some way
before it gets to the API then you don't
have control over that but hopefully
that's being tested on there and so
that's when you need to reach out to
them and say what gives anyone else all
right well thank you very much for
coming out and I'm happy to answer
questions afterwards
you